I get asked a lot about the interviews
about you know the workout routines that
we do and you know the fitness that
schedule that we're on and the whole
band's involved mostly guys in the band
and sometimes the crew guys as well and
so it's hard sort of harder in a
ten-minute interview to give you sort of
an idea of what we do you can give you a
little bit of a thumbnail sketch of what
we do but but the why we do it how we do
it you know some some basic food ideas
and stuff it's hard to do that in an
interview so that's really where the
book came from this trying to be sort of
inspirational motivational at the same
time and and not just you have to be
some sort of super athlete to get
yourself fit or at least get on the
track of a sort of wellness with body
and mind you know you it just starts
with with small things and um and let
those things lead to bigger things don't
take for granted the love this life
gives when you get where you're going
don't forget turn back around help the
next one
always stay hold on we were at a movie
theater I guess it was about ten years
ago and my daughter's were there and was
during the holiday season we were seeing
a holiday movie and I had assumed a
holiday movie so but I wasn't thinking
about it expect to see a trailer of my
movie to be in there and so we set out
in the trailer started sure enough the
trailer the movie I was in came in and
my face was the first thing that popped
on the screen and this you know those
huge screens and my daughter looked over
at me says jeez she need to do something
and seriously it sort of made me think
you know I I knew it and I saw it and I
always worked out um lifted and stuff
but I didn't take it as serious as I do
now or should have always do when I was
not taking care of myself at all and
drinking too much and all those things
my wife told me that you know you need
to clean yourself up you got some you
got some responsibilities here you know
if you don't clean yourself up you might
not be seeing me around for it
that'll kick your neck really quick me I
started with walking I mean my like I
said I'd always been an athlete and
always you know played basketball on the
road did all kinds of things but when I
came to it when it came to having a sort
of a focused workout the first thing I
started to do is walk and that led to
running and then running led to CrossFit
and lifting weights without even
noticing an unknown notice I'd do a lot
of things now in my show that that come
directly from some of the workouts that
I did certainly some of the bodyweight
stuff and sort of the mobility stuff
that I do with Roger who's the guy's
trained me for five or six years now
the stuff that I do with him it shows up
on stage and also just singing just a my
singing my condition the condition that
I think I've seen better now than I ever
have and I think that's a big part of
the workouts in the exercise and the
fitness um it gives me all kinds of
latitude to do the things that I want to
do on stage and not worry so much about
having to catch my breath and sing the
song